31 year old making his 28th start the
earth while marlin and cincinnati red
era right at 333 opponents only hitting
225. you know when he gets ahead of
right-handers 213 hitter left-handers
239 he's having a good season and the
rotation for the giants are having a
great year as well 1-1 bouncing ball to
the right side la stella angles back
into his left leans over to field it now
straightens up and throws out griflin
for out number one one-two pitch machado
loops one out into right center field
duggar is there on the move he's gonna
race over and make the catch on the run
to take away a hit from manny machado
jake garrietta on the hill tonight for
the friars 35 year old veteran third
start as a padre tonight career at
oracle park four and three record with
an era of just under five
up the middle face hits center field and
la stella was pretty firm for a change
up he had to go down to get it
brandon belt lifts it in the air down
the left field line towards the corner
profile headed over and he makes the
catch
kind of went into a slide there and
racing back is lu stella
and he'll come off the bag
turns it into a double play check out
the way he catches this one
he breaks it down then pops immediately
right back up runner is off first base
quick release too two outs base is empty
to posey he swings it's a high drive
deep left field pro far back at the wall
it is gone up into the bleachers buster
posey first inning home run
number 18 of the year for posey one
nothing giants posey hit that hard 2-2
pitch is called strike three right on
the outside perfect pitch another slider
out number one two down in the second
inning and brings up adam frazier
by the dive of brandon crawford into
left center and a base hit for adam
frazier with two down here in the second
inning thought that one off the pitch
meyer strikes out swinging
he gets in with the slider so the padres
get their first hit but they do not
score
down and chris bryant comes to the plate
chris didn't play yesterday
that one is hit hard deep center field
grisham going back it is off the wall
grisham throwing in towards second cut
off a stand-up double for brian two on
one out for duggar
right down the middle again but that
one's in there for strike three went to
the change-up and really baffled him
that strikeout number three for arietta
the arm swing got him and the depth of
this pitch got him fooled him so much
taken right down the middle just above
the knees two out walk to the pitcher to
load the bases and bring up a guy who
already has a hit in the game tommy
lestella pause the belt the o2 to
lustela is swung on and grounded to the
right side frazier to his left has it
from the outfield grass second baseman
throws to first in time to get la stella
far rounding for the first time tonight
getting the start in the left field one
and two to pro farm is swung on and
ripped out towards the right center
field gat long run yastranski's got no
shot all the way into triples alley and
profile certainly thinking about three
rounding second now he will slam on the
brakes crawford's throw goes over to
third base lead double for jerks and pro
far here in the third inning and the
padres will have the potential tying run
in scoring position so profile to third
base now one out so runner on third one
out for grisham trent left-hand hitter
goes after the first pitch ground ball
to second let's stella coming home not
in time throw to first is in time game
tied one one first third one down for
brandon crawford struck out swinging in
the second inning for one posey at third
trying to get him home it doesn't
necessarily take a hit to do it and a
wild throw
posey comes in to score wade goes to
second
two to one giants a wild pick-off throw
by arietta wow well that scores the run
it takes away the force i mean that is a
huge
huge mistake for marietta
ground ball right side of the backhand
goes frazier
throw dug out nicely by hosmer as wake
junior takes third base runner on third
two outs first pitch on the way bryant
swings hits a ground ball right at
fraser second baseman's got it right of
the bag long throw to first in time and
that's it for the giants here in the
third they get an unearned run on a
couple of hits and an error by jake
arrieta
second with two way here for the giants
on top two to one
and hits the first pitch up the middle
into center field base hit
that's going to score steven duggar
easily three to one giants tommy
lestella does not wait around and he
promptly drives in the run
belt up the middle into center field he
gets a hit against hill but gabe
kepler's sticking with his lefties
against tim hill now they're making him
look good
to third and machado thought about going
to second but he goes to first for the
out and the inning comes to a close
giants get the one on a couple of hits
they also leave two men aboard giants
have two on one out here in the bottom
of the fifth inning kicks and deals
ralph swings and pops it up
right side of the infield hosmer and
fraser both there it'll be frazier
making the call and the two-handed catch
as he backpedals onto the outfield grass
this is filled with giants with two down
here in the bottom of the fifth inning
on top three one again we'll see one and
two diesel funny trying to check his
swing could not he strikes out and the
inning is over so ross detwiler with
kind of an adventurous padre debut in
the bottom of the fifth inning
rosie's home run the only home run of
the game here's a swing and a fly ball
center field
not deep coming in duggar he almost
overruns it and he leaps up to make the
catch for out number one all's well that
ends well
that thing was not hit very hard he came
racing in like he needed to
to really hurry
and then ended up almost over running
the ball but he
made a nice play to reach up and catch
it one and one here's the pitch meyers
hits a high fly ball
shallow center duggar coming in
makes the call and duggar makes a catch
two down and myers retired gabe kepler
with tony watson ready in the bullpen
comes out to speak to dee slefani now
well if he doesn't throw another pitch
he's had an outstanding outing tonight
watson throws profile strikes out
swinging fastball 93 miles an hour got
him tony watson comes in and gets
through the top of the seventh two down
brandon crawford still at first base and
here is darren ruff ruff drives one out
to the gap in right center field this
one is going to get one hop up against
the wall and bounce on the fence and
stay in play coming around third is
crawford he'll come in to score into
second with a double darren ruff and
it's four to one giants
one on and that'll bring up brandon belt
now a swinging a drive out toward the
gap in left center field grisham's not
going to get this one one hop up against
399. speeding around the third estrada
he'll fly home and score and it's 5-1
giants
softly hit
machado with a great arm
wild throw
and we were told that those nets except
the ones right behind the dugouts
are in play well it went right behind
the railing and it kind of tucked itself
in
i mean that should be
a dead ball
and should be out of play
and an extra base to enable belt to
score and posey to go to second all
right here's the call
yeah you go home
brandon belt you score buster posey you
go to second
so the wild throw by manny machado
which we don't see too often
and that's the second run of the inning
six to one
doval has come into pitch for the giants
going back and under it lamont way
junior and the giants nine game winning
streak is in the books
you